good morning today is a beautiful
saturday
papa's in california but me and tyka
yeah
i did it by myself yep he poured his own
cereal
but the big big big part that he did
really good was pour his own milk and he
didn't even spill anything good job dude
and you put on your own pajamas i didn't
help you
i put on you put on your onesie
so we're gonna eat some cereal
and watch a movie baby yeah it's early
morning it's 7 a.m
[Music]
and he loves the weekend
it's so funny how he just started school
i'm thirty-fourth from the cons and gave
me presents in 24 days
i think it's less than that but um yeah
it's so funny to me that he just started
school he's only been in school
spider-man you want to watch spider-man
um
[Music]
oh god dang this dude's posse
it's funny to me he's only been in
school for like
six months and he's already over it
dude
i understand your pain
hey today we're gonna buy christmas
presents for everyone right
i love this because last year was the
first year he was coherent and like
aware enough to buy all his loved ones
uh present so we went to like the 99
cent store and he picked out
his own presents
for people and it was the coolest [ __ ]
ever so i'm gonna do it again this year
i'm excited
okay sit down
right here
all right monkey
so we're gonna do some christmas
shopping yeah baby
but we have to figure out who we're
gonna buy presents for okay
okay that's your cousin okay let me see
i'm gonna say
taikas
taika's
christmas
list
well this marker's cool okay we said
dominic
derek
who else
you're theo tutu and
the arena your theorena and grandma
grandma
and
[Music]
mommy
okay leilani
jay jay
uh
the neighbors
what's that stay before where you should
cross her at the second house
was next to duterte's house oh your
cousin
you know yeah i don't know the name yeah
the neighbor shows his toys
[Music]
was i there yeah in the neighborhood
okay fine what else who else grandpa
yeah
plus
[Music]
[Laughter]
what about uh your coach
tg what about your cobra kai friends
what about your school friends uh
kai
kai oh coach kai yeah oh that's so nice
and what about the other teacher which
one i know he had no hair coach tg
and what else
what about your teachers
um miss mr mila yeah
and skylar
elizabeth
and
lammy
nemmy yeah emmy this is fred
an argent
okay
and makes it
okay
and
what else hmm
[Music]
santa brings the presents uh
what else i don't know i think that's it
that's your stuffed animal like he can
have a plan what about enzo and leia um
what about his dad
his mom do you have christina
[Music]
[Music]
and dustin
dustin yeah how about that
oh
justin
okay
[Music]
well there's so many people
um
[Music]
okay we're done
okay so we're gonna get out of these
onesies
we're gonna get dressed it's a brisk
66 today yeah
hey dude
so yeah we're gonna get dressed and
we're gonna go get christmas presents
and taika i'm so proud of you he always
wears um i always have him sleep in
pull-ups
and i think out of like the hundred
pull-ups that he's had
i think he's only wet the bed no not
what the bed he's never been with the
bed um but i think he's only peed in
them maybe once or twice and that's
because it was really cold
huh
at night
dude
okay i'm ready never paired these guys
up
not sure it matches but sometimes you
just gotta say f it
and you just gotta wear it
because at the end of the day because it
[ __ ]
it's just close
over here we got
the dude
making it work
good job i'll help you
what is this
what's going on over here
a chair cause you wanna get some snacks
yeah baby oh thank you baby okay don't
forget to put the chair back okay
okay
smart guy
what kind of snacks did you get
oreos man you're so lucky
growing up i didn't have any of this
stuff you know your mom had to walk
10 miles to the liquor store to buy one
stick of gum you know that
it feels good a lot
now i get where my parents
my parents got it from and why they did
it it's fun you can just make up any
[ __ ]
they make it sound crazy
hello chicas okay you ready to go
shopping yeah poop let's go sorry mama
thank you you're welcome
we're working on it
so i'm bringing tyka to
the 99 cent store
because i feel like it's the most
affordable for what he wants to get has
a lot of options don't have to think
about a budget very much
so we did this last year it was a hit
and it's just so funny to see what it
how he sees the people that he's buying
the gift for
like what he sees they need or how he
gets excited about what he's about to
gift them but on our way here i want to
take a 15-minute drive
we lost him guys
he's out
don't be fooled by the shades
there's nothing behind them
what the hell is all this
wait for it
look at this
they're just camping out
do you [ __ ] know that you guys
can fly
do you know how vulnerable you guys are
right now on the ground like the rest of
us peasants can you guys go in a tree
and [ __ ] and get away from us hello
look at them just chilling
look look you're gonna get ran your ass
over by a car cause you're stupid
okay so i drove around for over an hour
21 miles in
ended up at marshalls
he's still knocked out i even picked up
some dutch bros i don't know why they
don't market their cups anymore but
they're not marketing them anymore for
some
reason i should look that up
um
but yeah he should be waking up any
minute now
i hope
he's snoring like a [ __ ] though
thank you
i get a lot of that because of my rep on
my car
i'm not mad at it but yes we are awake
we're doing our wiggle wiggles
oh oh my god
ready to shop yeah baby you look like an
angel in this light baby
no angels don't do that
[Music]
so far doing pretty good wait
what are you doing
bozo
well i was about to say we just got home
but this dude's just giving you all
kinds of dances oh no dude please stop
eating look what you're doing
stop eating
hold on i'll go get this to the plate
okay so we decided not to go with the
plate he went with a wrapper okay so
we're back home
we only did um marshall shopping i hate
shopping that was already so
much work for me and luckily there was
like almost no one there because
everyone likes to procrastinate
which is good for me
because i don't when it comes to this
[ __ ]
which i feel like i'm already
procrastinating honestly it's like the
beginning of the not even the first week
in december and i'm already like i'm so
late
and for my non-procrastinators out there
you feel me on it like i feel like i'm
already so late
um but i got so much stuff
so many people
rock you yeah i got so many things and
my family actually watches my vlogs so
i'm not gonna share too much of what i
got
but let's just say
marshalls in las vegas
is awesome it is fully stacked and
loaded out here
can you go with your ice cream what are
you even doing over here
this dude loves the camera so much like
any time i'm vlogging he has to be right
next to me in front of the camera
i know i mentioned that i was probably
gonna start taking him off once he
started going to school but as you can
see
this was an entertainer
and what he's looking at is actually his
own reflection so he's entertaining
himself
and don't you start telling me oh he
needs another baby sister another baby
brother no
we're done you don't get to decide or
tell me
when i should or shouldn't have kids so
stop saying that thank you very much
goodbye to choose yep
goodbye
come on come on
go eat your ice cream dude
tag and i are having ice cream tech is
having
a dryers
oh jesus i think maybe every time i turn
on the camera that's what happens it's
my fault
and i'm having
cold stones coffees lover delight
i bought
whatever this is a pint two pints
i don't know how much this is
it's so good it has almond it's coffee
flavored i don't even like the flavor of
coffee it has heath bars in there
caramel you see that right there
bro
this is
delicious do yourself a favor
and avoid coffee lovers delight at all
costs at all costs do not get coffee
lovers delight
don't go to cold stones right now do not
do it and do not get cold
coffee lovers are like please i beg you
please don't get it
this is that good
and you're not gonna be able to stop and
then you're gonna hate me because i
ruined your life
so please don't get coffee lovers
delight please don't do it
not spawn
now we're in the garage i'm about
seventy percent done with my workout
yeah one second we'll get to you not yet
not yet
i just did 190
three by three i thought i was gonna die
now i'm doing a circuit
salt bike walking lunges
i met about twists okay show us your
drone and this is one of the things we
got from marshalls for like seven bucks
it's really cool show me drone
i swear
he looks so big to me now
he's a big little boy okay go
turn it on
there you
go careful
no no no put it up up up
no not like that no
what happened
you got scared
don't be a don't be scared do it and
just hold it out like that just follow
the rules and nothing's gonna happen to
you do it no you do it
turn it on what are you doing give me
your hand
turn it on though is that you need two
hands turn it on
don't don't put it next to your face
like i said
it's not on
here give me your hand
okay
there it is let like stop stop stop
leave it alone that's why it hits you
leave it alone okay it's gonna hit you
because you're not listening to me and i
told you to let it go
look at that face because you know i'm
right
that was a good that was a back row uh
back roll
backwards shoulder roll
well anyway
you got this really cool drone excuse me
[Music]
oh shoot oh shoot it's going the wrong
way
why is it going that way
oh maybe because we oh that's why we
broke it over here okay well we'll fix
it but yeah you get the idea
[Music]
yep
got smarty
[Music]
yup good night duty duty poop we're off
to bed
[Laughter]
see you later see you tomorrow
she is a baby